today we're gonna examine the future of
ovale after he became one of the few
characters in Maya academia to get
skywalk good two times I my ad using
information from the latest ultra
analysis book I'm gonna explain whether
he'll ever be able to use his quark
again and then lay out the four most
likely scenarios for the future of this
character but before we begin make sure
you subscribe as I think we have a small
chance of hitting 30,000 by the end of
January okay so for those that missed it
both of overhauls arms were destroyed by
the league of villains in the latest
episode with mr. compressed getting
revenge for what happened to him earlier
on in the season and because overhauls
quark only works when he touches things
with his bare hands he is now officially
Quercus now after this incident occurred
overhaul was taken to Tartarus which is
the same prison where all for one and
stained are both being held
basically you're only allowed to go to
this prison if you've been worked by one
of the main cast now whilst it's
incredibly ironic that the man who
sought to destroy quarks is now Quercus
himself there's information from the
ultra analysis book that implies that
this might not be the end of monster all
his profile in the book says that he's
been medically treated but more
importantly that his quirk has been
remodeled now obviously to remodel
something that means you're
fundamentally changing it so it's
unlikely that it would be close to his
full powers at least not anytime soon in
all likelihood the remodeling of a quark
like overhauls probably means that he's
able to reassemble things but
potentially not disassemble things and
unlike mr. compress
overall would have gotten a good
standard of care because his quark was
remodeled whilst he was in custody so
presumably he was receiving some kind of
government health care as opposed to
being fixed up in a dark alleyway which
is most likely what happened to mr.
compress but anyway even with overhauls
quark partially restored with the
potential of it being fully restored one
day there's still the fact that he's
locked up in Tartarus this prison is
located so far away from civilization
and as all for once said inmates have
their brain waves monitored and if they
think about activating their quarks then
they might potentially even be shot so
even if chisaki does get back to near
full power
he will definitely not be using his
quark anytime soon if he knows what's
good for him but that's everything we
know regarding his quark so far it's not
really been touched on in the manga so
this text from the ultra analysis Berg
is basic
everything we have to go off from right
now not moving on I see for realistic
pause for the future of this character
and - spoiler warning ahead for the
manga so if you don't want to know
anything at all then this is the end of
the video for you my friend let's get
into the four most realistic paths for
the future of this character so firstly
overhauls extensive knowledge of the
quote destroying bullets may actually
work in his favor here we know for a
fact that the League of villains wants
to use them as they went through all the
trouble of hijacking a police vehicle
and even killing a pro hero just to get
a few of them and in the manga we've
seen that Shigure Aki has actively tried
to replicate these bullets with no
success so my theory is this now that
sugar Aki has incredible power at his
disposal at some point in the near
future he's most likely going to attempt
a prison break to get all four one out
of Tartarus and whilst he's doing that
we obviously know that chisaki is being
kept there so it's a possibility that
overhaul could leverage his knowledge of
these quote destroying bullets in
exchange for sugar Aki giving him one of
the quirk restoring bullets boggles the
guy who values his quirks so much so I'm
pretty sure he would do anything to get
it back and shake Iraq he's a guy who
desperately wants to recreate these
bullets but has no means of doing so
over who could tell him that he knows
the secret of how to create more and I
he'll do it if they restore his quirk
and he'll even if they couldn't restore
his quirk they still have all four one
on that team like he could just give
overall a brand new quirk that's even
better now there is bad blood between
overhaul and the league of villains
after day you know destroyed his arms
but even with that being the case I mean
he would still want his full work back
cuz we know it's been remodeled but that
means it's basically not the same as it
used to be although just thinking about
it now I'm not sure if the quote
restoring bullets were finished but
whether they are or not Shigure Aki has
the resources on his side to be able to
capture area and start making more of
these quote restoring birds and quote
destroying bullets however I doubt this
guy would that happen anyway the next
most realistic part for overhaul is a
lot darker so if the villains do break
into Tartarus and start freeing their
allies then all for one would be top of
the list but number two on that list
would be courier II now cure Geary has
one of the best quirks in the anime as
he can teleport someone to a
predetermined location what if they were
to secure Gary free and then use him to
teleport villains in Tartarus
to a predetermined location where they
could harvest their choir
overhauls quark factor still exists so
they could still harvest his original
disassembling and reassembling quark if
they wanted to all they would have to do
is get Kira Geary to send overhaul to
dr. Jake oh and within a few minutes I'm
sure you could get a brand new nomu who
could disassemble and reassemble matter
and if nothing else I'm sure awful one
would love to take his quark if given
the chance so yeah it's possible that
things might get even worse for chisaki
the third possibility is probably the
most unlikely but it is possible over
who might actually work with the police
and heroes to take down the league of
villains if we just take a step back
Shikha rocky gave this guy a fate that
he probably considers to be worse than
death in retaliation I mean it's not
crazy to say they he'd cooperate with
police or whoever else to try and take
down the league of villains or on the
other side he could be used to help the
heroes in a different way
we know that Ares rewind quark has
unbelievable potential and no one has
studied it more of an overhaul and as
we've seen she has no idea how to
control it
so potentially in the future it is
possible that maybe I Sawa or me Rio
visits over Hall in prison at some point
to discuss Ares quark and how she can
use it properly we saw in a recent
chapter in the manga heiress quark was
getting a bit uncontrollable again maybe
because she hadn't used it for a long
time so whatever the reason for this is
it's clear that if she doesn't use it
for a certain amount of time it will
start to cause her discomfort or even
pain so it's possible that chisaki could
be used in the future in this way but I
know what you're thinking
why would he help arrey in any way I'm
not speaking from experience when I say
this and I haven't been locked up in
jail but maybe if he's had time to think
about his crimes he might have realized
that it wasn't worth torturing a little
girl just so that his gang of cosplayers
could come out of the shadows look at
you now mate like was it worth it no so
it's possible that he might be a bit
repentant but in all likelihood probably
not but that my friends brings us to the
final possibility for the future of oval
and a lot of people will almost
definitely agree that this is the most
likely scenario to happen in 4th place
we have the idea that overhaul is never
seen and never heard from again in many
ways overhaul was a plot device in the
story to show us why sugar Rocky will be
the true villain of Maya academia they
both wanted to replace all-4-one as the
king of the underworld and their quirks
aren't that dissimilar
at least the destruction as
but ultimately in the end over who was
the one who failed as Shiraki just swept
in and took away his life's work with
that being the case shiitakes relevance
to the remainder of the story is
probably gonna be limited to two things
number one is his impact on area and
number two is the quirk destroying and
quite restoring bullets that he created
although as I said I don't think the
coop restoring bullets are completely
finished these are the things that
overhaul has either created or affected
in very serious ways and so from that
point of view maybe overhauls just
served his purpose in the story and now
his legacy lives on through Arry and the
bullets for me personally I loved
overall as a villain a few of you
already know this but the overall arc
was actually my favorite arc in my
academia it gave us some amazing moments
including when overhaul got jumped by a
six-year-old girl and a kid in his first
year of high school good times good
times but yeah that's gonna do it for me
today guys we went through the
possibility of overall getting his quirk
back and also went through the four most
likely scenarios for the future of this
character and I'm actually not sure
which one is the most likely because I
know a prison-break arc will almost
definitely happen in the future but
whether overall is relevant to that I
mean it's purely up to her Co she thanks
for watching and peace out